[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the Ziegfeld Cup the
last qualifying stop on the grand
Chester
we had an incredibly exciting event this
year it was down to the wire down to the
very last game before we decided the
winners such an incredible event and we
have to thank these illustrious players
for making that happen everyone please
give a hand to our grandmasters not that
you don't know their names but before
going on to introduce them I first like
to thank Shannon Bailey and the world
chess Hall of Fame for hosting the event
is such a spectacular location continues
to do great work thank you very much
Shannon and your staff of course none of
this is possible without the largesse of
Rex and dr. Janey Sinquefield they have
really made chess special here in st.
Louis and ended the United States at
large making st. Louis now the capital
of chess in the US and there I say the
capital of chess in the world so thank
you very much Rex and dr. Jeanne
Sinquefield
the grin chest or consists of many other
cities or at least a couple of other
cities and we'd like to thank those
cities as well starting with Levine
Belgium where we had a very spectacular
event one by this gentleman to my right
Wesley so the organizer yon kill avert
of your next move Ches yeah and wherever
you are watching thank you so much and
in Paris we also have some spectacular
organizers Jill Betts Houser of Colliers
International and also Vivendi and all
the staff there the studios that put on
such a great show thank you as well
Paris and of course st. Louis we're here
we had the st. Louis rapid and blitz
event also a very exciting event by the
way Paris was won by Hikaru Nakamura and
he managed to do the double and win here
in st. Louis the rapid and blitz event
and all that happens because of the
great staff here led by executive
director Tony rich
thank you very much Maurice and thank
you all for coming tonight I mentioned
at the opening ceremony that you know
chess has always been something I've
been passionate about since I started
playing in high school and I ran my very
first chess club there you know seeing
these players here today is yet another
testimony to the great things that we're
doing you know it's not just that these
great players are here but it's that
they've become role models for the
students who play the game of chess now
we have programs in about a hundred
schools in the st. Louis area and each
one of them are following these games
they're following these players some of
them have even come down to the Chess
Club to be able to get an autograph from
their favorite player and it's the
reason we do it it's the reason we're
all here in fact is because we believe
that st. Louis is a great city we
believe that the students that are in
these programs are going to be well we
know that they're going to be the future
members of our society and so we're very
grateful to the players for creating
such excellent role models and becoming
such actually role models for all of the
students that we have so thank you all
for joining us and thank you for being
here thank you so much well this may be
the last opportunity this year to do it
so I would like to thank the players one
by one by just introducing them we have
been watching them over the last 10 days
but they should get their applause for
being such spectacular players such
amazing fighters and all-around great
gentlemen so I will call their names one
by one starting from Russia Grandmaster
Sergei Kuryakin
web Minister Chakri Armani tear off from
Russia grandmaster Alexander grishko
from our media grandmaster Levon Aronian
to my right from the USA Grandmaster
Wesley so from India grandmaster
Vishwanath on aa
[Applause]
boom friends grandmaster vaccine Maxime
la Sheila Gras Grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura from the USA World Championship
challenger Fabiano Caruana the world
champion Magnus Carlsen
[Applause]
and I always have the honor of being
able to introduce these two people in
particular dr. Jeanne sing feel - I hear
wears the pants in the family
Jeanie he's always a great commentator
he says nice things about me this has
been so much fun
remember the nine days ago I said it'd
be sort of fun to have a new winner
didn't expect we would have a three-way
tie so you guys did what I want just in
a slightly different way so this has
been lots of fun great things we've had
I'm looking at you we've got the former
grand chest or by former Sinquefield Cup
winners no new ones because they tied
world champions former world champions
this is probably the elite this is the
best group you're ever gonna see in Jess
here in st. Louis so how could a big
grounder Klaus
[Applause]
and so I always get to introduce Rex so
where are we sitting competing so I'm
doing my Scouts with 990,000 just merit
badges out there build our audience and
he's trying to beat me by doing it here
in st. Louis it's only up to about 5,000
kids we're working on it so they
introduced the Godfather of American
chess my loving husband Rex Sinquefield
[Applause]
Thank You genie Thank You Maurice the
players in the commentator is just an
amazing job an amazing tournament Randy
and his team at Spectrum and 'gta and
the crew at silver backed a mimosa
Leonard all of you who made the
broadcast and live show an incredible
success thank you very much the staff at
the Chess Club in the world chess Hall
of Fame worked so well together and do
an incredible job day in and day out
thanks to all of you for everything you
do and of course the very best in the
world
Yaser Maurice Jennifer Peter mural the
best broadcasters of any sport on this
planet thank you very much for once
again an incredible job and Fabiano
Magnus and LaVon all of you had an
amazing tournament you caused some help
heart palpitations I think your future
tournaments are like this we're gonna
have cardiologist on standby here but
all of you had an amazing tournament you
created real history in this year's
thing field Cup and we congratulate all
of you now it's my honor to introduce
the man who runs the entire st. Louis
County the best County Executive in the
United States the Honorable Steve
stinger
[Applause]
well that's quite a title I appreciate
that thank you very much I think I got
promoted but I thank you all very much I
have to mention former mayor Francis
Slay is here as well it's great to see
you here as you all know he's a great
supporter of chess as the 2018 SiC field
Cup draws to a close we salute all of
the competitors and congratulate the
winners who emerge from these contests
as the finest players in the game and I
want to salute Rex and Jean ecig field
for promoting the great game of chess
and our hometown that is just so
important and behalf of our entire
region I also want to thank you for the
historic donation that they made today
to st. Louis University a 50 million
dollar gift for creating a new fund to
finance faculty research hire new
professors and finance scholarships in
the humanities
[Applause]
and with that said there is a rumor
going around that the cig fields
attached a certain stipulation to their
gift and that was that slew replace its
clock tower with a giant chess piece
Rex there's no truth to that is there
okay we're just making sure but
seriously the entire st. Louis region
benefits from the Ziegfeld sponsorship
of the great game of chess and the
world-class competitions in our own town
the estimated economic impact of the
many visitors who attended these
contests over the past few weeks will be
calculated and it will be significant
well in excess of a million dollars
again I appreciate the opportunity to
participate in this event and thanks
again to Rex and Jeanne Ziegfeld for
their support of the entire st. Louis
region thank you very much well this cup
had its moments and it had its historic
conclusion instead of having just one
repeat winner as was mentioned we had
three and they did it in a variety of
ways all of it very exciting and we are
deeply appreciative to be able to talk
about these games they these gentlemen
play because they are indeed the legends
of our game just simply incredible chess
so I get the honor of this time of
actually announcing three separate
winners it's hard to pick an order so
I'm going to pick it by the order that
they concluded the victory first of all
this gentleman showed his class by
winning the game and chasing having two
people chase him throughout the event
almost could have just sealed the deal
but he was caught at the end
nevertheless with no losses perfect
score in two wins the first winner of
the Sinquefield Cup repeat winner of the
Sinquefield cup from the USA world
championship challenger Fabiano Caruana
[Applause]
this next gentleman played gangster
chess
his sacrifice of a rook on f7 in a
situation that really was going for it
all and he could have lost it all if he
didn't win the game just showed his
courage his heart his desire and the
fact that he just likes to have a lot of
fun when he plays he is also a repeat
winner putting his name edging his name
on the trophy for a second time from
Armenia grandmaster Levon Aronian and
this gentleman has been doing it just
about all his life takes a position that
looks to everybody like it's drawn and
he keeps it going and he keeps it going
and you have to stay with him because
he's relentless he ball constrictor
creating threats from any angle even
ghost threats maybe and scares everyone
who's playing against them you've got to
be perfect and defense and any mistake
he punishes and he was the last to
finish 97 moves before he finally could
clinch that tie from Norway the world
champion Magnus Carlsen
[Applause]
and I would like for the players to say
a few words I know you'd like to thank
word of thanks so first starting with
you Fabiano how does it feel to have the
trophy back at home yeah it feels
amazing - it's been so many years since
I had a great tournament here and I mean
it couldn't have gone better I think
there were some exciting moments and I
think that in mind there was a fair
shared victory I think also Magnusson
level and fully deserved the first place
and they fought very hard in the last
round and of course I would like to to
thank everyone who made this tour an
apostle in all the tournaments all the
great tournaments around the year in st.
Louis everyone at the Chess Club and
everyone at the Hall of Fame who make
these events run so smoothly and all the
commentators and the arbiters who help
the players feel comfortable and help
the viewing public enjoy the spectacle
and I'd especially like to thank dr.
Jeanne and Rex Sinquefield for promoting
the game of chess and for making San
Luis such a great chess city and I'd
also like to thank my parents in the
second row for being here and for
supporting me
[Applause]
and LaVon you you did play this gangster
move rogue takes on f7 and got all of us
extremely excited it could have gone the
other way but it managed you managed to
pull it together and show your class and
finish the game off in style your
thoughts on this event I think it was
kind of symbolical to have you know ten
years of this wonderful organization and
support towards our game to have shared
victory so because we all the players
are so grateful to the single family for
what they're doing and we've been just
blessed with it with everything you know
just being here so I guess that's why I
wanted to have some fun and I always
want to have fun here the only problem
is that the last time I won the
tournament here I've bitten three
Americans so this time there were only
two players from Russia instead of three
if there were three I would have some
chances so I I would like to thank the
people who support our game and give us
this incredible tournaments and I hope
that there are many many more years
coming and we'll pray for your health
Jeanne and Rex and thank thanks to all
the volunteers and everybody who works
to the club and makes chess great in
America thank you
and Magnus you had one in the first year
but came ever so close never finishing
worse than second place in the others
how does it feel now to have your name
once again edged on the cup well I mean
frankly speaking I was I was second
three times wasn't particularly close to
winning any of them so especially that
one year with with Fabi so but I cannot
say that I echo Levin's sentiment that
it's nice to share the victory it's much
nicer to win on your own I think I think
the fun also would would agree with with
that
having said that for me personal it's
obviously it's obviously a massive sum
had bit of a drought not only in this
particular tournament but also in
tournaments of this stature with only
with only such world-class players have
usually been been been second recently
so I'm very happy to share first place
and it's it's been a wonderful
experience here once again with with
with the club and everything so I'm I'm
thankful for for the opportunity to play
here and I'm thrilled about the result
I'm going to open up a question to the
audience anyone from the press who has a
quick question for the players asked
question is from Magnus I heard you say
a couple of times in the commentary that
you got nervous during your games and I
think that would surprise a lot of
people that you still get nervous so
whether it's something particular to
this tournament or is that just a
natural state and you admitted it a
couple times during the event well I've
been telling people all my life that I
get nervous but they never listens I
think I think it's it's part of being
really competitive and really caring
about the the results that nerves are
bound to to creep in at some point so I
think it's it's it's part of the game
and learning to master it takes a
lifetime for most people so I'm hoping
to together eventually
Fabiano I have a question for you and
I'd like for you to think about as well
Magnus people try to set up this event
as a possible preview in some way of
what you two are going to experience in
November it's all even drawing your
individual game and a tie at the end of
it what did what do you perceive as it
meaning that you guys didn't do anything
to one-up each other at this tournament
oh he actually has a pretty much
identical result in terms of who we
beaten who we drew and I mean in my in
our individual encounter I was under a
very serious pressure so draw there was
what's quite good for me but yeah I
don't see you what burying this house on
the world championship match I mean we
both showed that we can fight for the
first place but this isn't really a new
thing and I'm still there's all to play
for
well I mean I don't mean to sound petty
actually I kind of do but I had an extra
black game so all right well with that
we is always a way to one-up each other
you know I go with that it is time to
take a photo and this will be a photo
like we've never taken three players
holding the trophy so I would like to
welcome all three players to come over
the trophy is heavy enough so we'll see
if we can share this photo if you you
may and if I may ask the sink feels also
to join them as everybody gets a hand on
the photo think they trying to get them
to lift it sideways to seem quite right
okay now how can they all get the hands
on the photos you got to work that out
surround it to get some photos sideways
will be very difficult because the
trophy looks better standing out Magnus
Levon you've got to get in there there
we go
all right they've worked it out they've
worked it out now he had a picture of
these illustrious players the fabulous
trio winning the Sinquefield Cup
each of them for a second time quite an
accomplishment
for these players as they're doing that
I will also mention that Sinquefield Cup
is the fourth qualifying spot on the
grand Chester and four players did make
it to London and this will not be the
end of this party as it will be very
exciting and we had a very exciting
finish as well players we got our photos
and the names will be etched on the
trophy as well well thank you players
you may sit back down as I said the
Sinquefield Cup is the fourth and final
qualifying spot on the grand Chester and
four players made it to London we played
all those events we tallied all those
points we had early leader
we had people over take the leaders and
actually at the very end of Fabiano
Caruana
showed us something special in order to
qualify as well so we like to
congratulate the four players who made
it and first of all in the number one
seed hey Cara Nakamura the number two
seed I need my commentator teams to help
me who's the number two seed is it is it
LaVon okay we got arguments going on but
I'm gonna trust Yasir Yasir has
definitively said the number two seed
will be Levon Aronian the number three
seed of Maxime vasila Gras and finally
with a finish that enthralled us all and
was a fitting conclusion to this entire
eternity of the grand chest or Fabiano
Caruana
they will be playing in London for a
total prize fund of $300,000 the winner
will take home a cooled 120 thousand
dollars for a few days work and not a
bad paycheck but before that we will
have the champion showdown headlined by
one Gary Kasparov every time he says
he's gonna stay in retirement
we don't believe him and we figure out a
way to pull him back out but yes Gary
always said there's only one place that
he cares to play and it's here in st.
Louis
well we thank you all for your time when
we are deeply appreciative of the fans
who follow us on Twitter and elsewhere
on YouTube
I thank my co commentators thank the
sinc feels once again the magic that is
here in st. Louis thank you everyone and
have a good night
[Applause]
[Music]